so animal feed the power
assalamu alayka wa rahmatullah will
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends and family should I say we
are one big family so today's video is
going to be about me and my intentions
the intentions problems that I had for
example when I started the Dawa the
YouTube for example when I'm a pop
public platforms when I'm given for
example talks how I battled with my
intentions and how I fought it and try
to better myself in the best ways
possible
so if I'll share with you guys because a
lot of people go for this intention
problems and sometimes we don't
understand the matter of intentions
really don't understand it you know
because which I will touch upon
so basically Byfuglien sisters when I
got into the Dawa seen the YouTube or
whatever it is they start to be honest I
wasn't really I didn't have it planned
out I'm gonna do videos I didn't me and
cameras were not made for each other but
as you can see they are my first love
from now on so basically I got into it
cetera and one of the biggest problems
that I had when I go into the matter of
YouTube and the videos is for example
one of the first things was for example
obviously why am i doing what I'm doing
you know am i doing it for the sake of
Allah am i doing it for fame am i doing
it for this or that yeah this is so
things that I had to question myself
when I'm just be I want to be honest
with you guys so you guys can understand
and see how I battled it cuz I didn't a
time human being and obviously I've seen
these kind of stuff so I'm gonna share
with you guys so the first thing was
basically when I got there I needed to
know why I'm doing what I'm doing so I
questioned myself and I said look the
youth have issues out there they're Xena
is a problem alcohol gambling drugs gang
etc etc these are problems and these are
problems that I want to help the youth
and you get it because I've come from
Daria and and I've seen these kind of
stuff you get I'm trying to say even
though I hundred hours stayed away from
alcohol drugs and certain things but
nightlife clubbing and I don't mean it
to exposing myself but I've seen it I've
seen the damages that it brings so
seeing that I want to convey it to my
brothers and my sisters and friends in
humanity to basically abstain from this
stuff so I knew why I wanted to do what
I wanted to do when it came to Dawa that
was something that I loved because I
didn't I was lost I lost want Allah
guided me and obviously we know the
professor was Salim said indeed none of
you truly believed in until you love for
yourself we love for your brother so
because we have Islam we believe it's
time with something real
amazing for all of us so we want to
share it so that's why I knew why I was
doing so I questioned myself and I
understood and I said okay I'm Dolittle
are my intentions are good now what just
could the intentions good at the
beginning doesn't mean it's gonna carry
on like that to the end because along
the way you get bombs this tight hands
on your case because if he sees you
doing something beneficial
insha'Allah Allah accepts it from us he
will be on our cases so with me one of
the things that struggle was is for
example releasing videos at the
beginning hamdullah when we have videos
that are each in five ten thousand views
we are happy that those amount of people
are benefiting but as time went by
Shaitaan will start to get to me and be
like okay I would have moments where I
will share a video and the Shh I would
make me feel like oh a five thousand
views or ten thousand views so what was
happening was I was starting to realize
why am i concentrating more on views you
get it so what it is is it's about
reflecting upon it
do you know you can't say okay oh my
gosh I'm a bad person for thinking I
that know your human being you're gonna
think of certain stuff of intentions
wise you get it so I understood that
problem and I said okay what can I do to
stop that so once I realized that and I
said okay because what happens is again
that makes you when you look at the
views in my head I was thinking okay
need to do this video better this time
so gonna hold on I said hold on a second
why am I trying to do this or that to
make a video better or reach further no
no no no no so I realized the problem
and I said how can I deal with this so I
had my way of saying you know what from
now on I don't care this is a lot of
youtubers go through this as well you
know what I specifically from as Muslims
this is wrong we should not have this
mentality we do our videos so people can
benefit so basically I understood and I
said you know what I don't care if I put
I set myself on my brain and I made it
what I love for him to help me and
purify my intention I said I'm doing
this video because it needs to be done
it's good it's gotta be done I don't
care if it if 500 people watch a
thousand people that's it
from that moment on I understood the
problem and I found a solution I said
look I don't care if it's ten thousand
five thousand three thousand views I
don't care anymore I'm doing a video
that needs to be done I put out there I
leave it I don't care so hum dinner I
battle that within those techniques and
tactics that I used and hamdulillah
I've come over that
praises and glory blooms Allah the
second thing that I the second thing
that I had an issue was with for example
my video you know the black Israelite
the the black Jewish towel to black
truth which you can see in this corner
when I was doing this video and this is
something that I want to share with you
guys is that day I wanted to get a
haircut like you know haircut you know
look nice but then I came to a
realization of why I'm why do I want to
get a haircut and why before what am i
doing the video because the video needs
to be done and they need our and so
people can watch the video and be
benefited or am i doing a video just to
look good for what so and this doesn't
mean just because oh you want to look
good music intensive no but at that
specific moment of time I thought to
myself no for me too I knew my
intentions were like not to look good
this that but for me to have that doubt
and think okay why did I why am i doing
that I the way I battled it is this is
me this is personal I said I'm not gonna
get a haircut that day I'm gonna go
looking
Rhaego like like what if I don't care so
I went that make specific day and I just
did a video as it is I did get my hair
cut see this is our way of battling your
intention do you think I'm trying to see
because you understanding a problem and
just to prove a point to yourself and
others wants out that look it's not
about how I look at this type Judy I'm
trying to say so what I did was I went I
didn't get a haircut I didn't go on just
wear like this close and once again I
repeat it this doesn't mean that on my
videos I do try to look good in a way to
be presentable not in a way of oh let
the people I'm trying to say none of
that so hamdulillah that was a second
problem that I had and this is how I
dealt with it and this is what you can
use is well which I will come to
insha'Allah now the third thing is when
I'm out in public people approach me
hundred they like the stuff that we do
me in ran brother or your own brother
Musa they're not stuff that so they just
can't want to take a picture this is one
of the things that is really hard
because when people come to you Shaitaan
is on your case when people come and
approach me and say can I take a picture
this start sheet on will come and make
you feel like you're something special
one of the ways that I found a way of
combating this and this relates to
exactly when I'm giving a talk is before
I start my talk and I read
wherever I am on TV camera whatever it
is I like to start my talk by saying oh
praise His glory and gratitude belonged
Oliphant Allah everything that we do we
do it with his permission so this helped
me to reassure myself and the person
opposite me so when somebody comes
assisting me I can watch your videos I
said may Allah bless you I can make dua
for me or praises and glory bloom -
lucky you know G I'm trying to say so
this was a way of me to convey to him
and say look at all pleased in glory
belong to Allah cause if it's not with
this permission Ali Dawa Dawa man or
young man or Moosa man
we are nothing we are nobody do you get
it so this was hamdulillah a really good
way now I know a lot of brothers out
there they say okay I've intention from
this start so I wouldn't stop doing
videos I stopped in Dawa no Aki because
I then day this is my advice to you if
you're in the Taoist scene
yeah there's shaytan's gonna be on your
kids all the time if Shaytan sees you
doing something beneficial it's gonna
try to stop it stop me from doing that
now at the same time that can be a test
from Allah to you so you just can't say
okay I give up
no no no no no you battle it you fight
it just the way I gave you a few
examples of how I do it you have to
battle it and try to you know try to you
know figure out ways of overcoming that
instead of saying oh I'll give up a
white flag no no you have to battle it
inshallah you know and one of the things
that really I remind myself of is as you
know the first three people are gonna
enter the Hellfire is the one who read
Quran the one who gave in charity and
the one who fought in the way of Allah
these are the first ones gonna enter the
Hellfire
listen to me carefully this is a hadith
that really makes me think and reflects
and purifies me intention I remind
myself of that every time the first one
is when Allah calls him and says what
have you done for me come here oh Allah
I read up around for you yeah he's gonna
say you are lying you read the Quran so
people can say you know the Dean you're
knowledgeable person go to the Hellfire
number to the one he's gonna say come
here what did you do for me oh Allah I
gave a charity in your wealth in
abundance and all my wealth I was gonna
say you're lying you did this so people
can say you're a generous man so you
didn't do it for my sake you did it so
people can say oh you're this for that
so Allah said take him to the Hellfire
the third man is the one who fought in
the way of Allah Allah say what have you
done after on this and that he's gonna
say you're lying you did this or they
can say you are a brave man so these are
the first three people that can enter
the Hellfire brothers and sisters
this really makes me try to prove my
intention as much as possible and deal
with it so these were the main three
problems that I had and another problem
was basically you know having special
effects with these kind of stuff on my
videos me personally I found that to be
affecting my intentions so due to that
you know like you know making videos due
to that I try my best to not have no
special effects or this is personal to
me it's just something for I'll share
with you guys now I hope you guys have
benefited from what I'm saying to you
and I don't want to finish there is we
really need to understand our intentions
because we have a narration from the
prophets allah salallahu selim from
Ammar ibn Khattab where he says that
every intention is based sorry every
action that you do is based on his
intentions if I'm migrating from here to
Scotland and if this were the sake of
Allah I will get rewarded accordingly to
that but if I am leaving here to go to
Scotland because there's a marriage
proposal and I want to get married then
my intentions for something else even
though you can make your intentions for
that to be for the sake of all that you
say o Allah going to Scotland to get
married to complete half my deed and
keep away from fitna I'm duelin you can
do that so do you hear what I'm trying
to say and this is really important and
there is a saying which I am not 100%
sure that one of the scholars back in
the time said that the greatest thing
that I have dealt with is my intentions
fighting my intelligence constantly is
the biggest battle that I have had
that's our basic bonds and sisters when
you are wearing the hijab right
obviously not brothers sisters and
brothers when you grow in your beard or
whatever it may be if your intentions
are for the wrong reason let me draw my
beard so I could look nice let me wear
my hijab because I want to look nice you
need to understand that you and you will
not be getting rewarded for that under
the a judgement you come to Atlanta oh
Allah I grew my beard or for example my
hijab for you Allah will say no you did
it because you wanted to look good you
wanted to look nice you know you did a
course of fashion accessory
you grew a real beard so you can look
nice the opposite gender so what's gonna
happen is you're getting no rewards so
you really need to understand and purify
intentions why am I wearing my hijab why
am i growing my beard why am I giving
Dawa
why am i nice to people why did
be nice to people you hear anyways but
I'm saying for the sake of Allah so your
intentions should be on point
otherwise your deeds do actions
nullified
they don't mean nothing you know they
don't mean nothing at all so brothers
and sisters this is about it from me
hope you guys have benefited in Xiaohua
and like I said once again that's the
way I buttered my intentions initially
you guys have benefited me always wanted
a grant every single one of you guys
Jenna and all previous glory and
gratitude belong to allah subhanaw taala
i am nothing i am nobody and i don't
mean in a way to be humble we are nobody
we do what we do for the sake of other
as much as we can your intentions are
never ever going to be hundred percent
never try to battle them battle them
insha'Allah that's about it for me have
a beautiful day to Allah I'm gonna have
a couple of videos at the end if you're
in Iran relationship and you want to
leave your boyfriend or your girlfriend
watch the videos at the end inshallah
that's about it